citizens of the reject Nation we are
going to watch today a very special Last
of Us video called unlocking a
surprising genius companion series part
one it's a very very long video this
will be the first video John and I are
covering together uh regarding last of
us since uh he has not played the game
he's covering it separately with Tara
Erickson and then I'm covering it with
Andrew Gordon but yeah film wise is a
new channel launched by Philip Molina
who you might know from his work with a
new rock stars but now he's got a new
channel going this video has been hyped
for me like non-stop I know that Philip
spent weeks on this video maybe a couple
of months heavy spoilers who's killing
it with his coverage for this series
right now actually said this is the best
video he's seen regarding the Last of Us
I've had several people hit me up saying
that maybe we should react to it yeah
I'm here to tell you that we are going
to do that right now you can subscribe
to filmwise link in the description box
uh you can check out the original video
I actually don't know what the angle is
on it I'm here to support and I want to
see what's going on and enough people
have asked us to check it out so here we
are to do it before we do that please go
ahead leave a like let's see what's in
store
[Music]
to make a
case what to do
Essence lightsaber first time Hollywood
took a swing it's kind of become this
elusive mystery an unattainable goal
since that Super Mario Brothers movie
there have been countless attempts but
all they've done is make it seem less
possible to translate the magic of a
video game narrative to any other screen
even the writer and showrunner of this
new Last of Us show Craig Mason long
before taking on this job agreed that
video game adaptations are historically
terrible a lot of these assets I think
ultimately become junk so I like a
mountain of failed adaptations behind
them a budget of over 100 million
dollars and an industry landscape that's
about ready to say yeah we only want
sequels and adaptations but let's go
ahead and forget about video games and
Source material because they don't work
there is an immense amount of pressure
for HBO to get it right this time so
then why would they give this seemingly
impossible task to the same guy who made
these movies but I can tell when
Danger's near I just
he made those movies yeah before
Chernobyl Craig Mason does not have the
most like dramatically Hefty or like
widely respectable filmographers had no
idea
holy crap I was I was really thrown for
a loop there yeah I think it even worked
as a hangovers or something like that
yeah well that's fascinating to hear I
mean I gotta say so far it's Hardy just
the setup for what we're about to watch
and yeah the editing on this is
phenomenal already what the TV
documentary here yeah it really feels
that way and I think what Last of Us is
getting right is the fact that they're
focusing on character and emotion first
before focusing on bringing gameplay to
life and I think that's a lot of time
where a lot of these video game
adaptations go wrong it's like what do
they enjoy most when they're actually
playing the game but always said if
you're gonna adapt something go for the
TV show because it started working out
pretty well for the animated medium when
they're doing that and now live action
they're proving it we're proving it here
welcome to filmwise in this three-part
mini-series we're going to be
dismantling the idea of The Impossible
Video Game adaptation and by analyzing
the structure of this story and of the
world the show takes place in we're
going to figure out what's really going
on here not just in the last of us but
in this seemingly insane choice to hand
the reins to Craig Mesa a choice he
himself knows is pretty scary they
didn't have to draw so much from my
bottomless well of self-loathing instead
I I borrowed from my bottomless well of
fear here's the thing Craig Mason is
exactly the right person to make this
adaptation a success the only wrong move
for him and for HBO would be to not even
try and much like the themes of this
story itself when it comes to Joel's
Journey the threat of a global pandemic
or protecting the ones you love the
greatest risk is not taking one by the
way if you're wondering where I'm
getting all this from well we're lucky
enough to have the words of Craig Mason
himself to help guide us in analyzing
what this story is really about my name
is Craig Mason and this is scriptnotes a
podcast about screenwriting and things
that are interesting to screenwriters on
a screenwriting podcast Craig Mason
tells us how he builds here's how he
says we should start but when you think
of the idea the very next question you
should ask is what central dramatic
argument would fit really well with this
that's how we made superhero movies
we'll be seeing multiple episodes of the
show at a time but in this video we're
going to focus mostly on the pilot
because it not only encompasses all of
act one of the larger story but each
scene within it is setting the
groundwork for all of the Mega themes
that will come later for instance in the
show's very first scene it immediately
is planting the seed for these Show's
entire Central dramatic arguments
the story not from the game it's a clip
from a 1968 TV talk show where a
scientist predicts how Humanity could
fall to a threat as seemingly benign as
a fungus but only if we ignore the
warnings of things like say global
warming what if the world was to get
slightly warmer well now there is reason
to evolve cordyceps aspergillus any one
of them could become capable of
borrowing into our brains and taking
control billions of Puppets permanently
fixed on one unifying goal to spread the
infection to every last human alive by
any means necessary the jokes that the
host makes indicates how their world
began to responded this morning but of
course that's not just true for their
world there is no pandemic flu in our
country at this time but if we wait for
a pandemic to appear it will be too late
to prepare we have to put in place an
infrastructure that allows us to see it
quickly isolate it quickly respond to it
quickly yeah that's something that I
think this show in particular better
than the video game does is draw on real
world things that people would say are
political but they're just scientific
[__] that we're dealing with all the
time and I think that this show really
knows how to demonstrate that in a
phenomenal way and I haven't seen
Chernobyl of what I imagine about what
goes on in Chernobyl Craig Mason already
had a really great knack for that to
implement some of those flourishes over
to here whereas a lot of shows and
movies might get too bogged down with it
he knows how to make it feel more lived
in and it was cool is that Chernobyl is
a true story and he's now taking this
into a fictional realm sure kind of
extrapolating off of that because so
much of Chernobyl is about watching the
human error and hubris that can lead yes
to a disaster such as this and then here
you multiply it by all these issues that
we can't seem to agree on just in
culture and those agreements could or
disagreements could be incredibly costly
as illustrated by what they're putting
out here and it's not overly preachy as
of now but it does seem like they did
put a solid effort into going yeah what
can we actually contemplate with all
this cool stuff that we're doing with
infectious and all that stuff what are
the dangers of inaction and we answer it
through the stories of Joel and Ellie
the global pandemic around them and
those around us I'm actually not talking
about covet here by the way but more on
that later and it even applies to Craig
Mason's own path in making this show and
if at any point you think I'm reaching
when I'm showing the true meaning of the
story has to do with something in our
world just know that's what Mason has
told us to look out for himself
everything we wanted to do was to say to
people listen we're showing you
extraordinary circumstances a world
that's Fallen apart and there are
monsters and all this stuff is happening
but it is applicable to your life right
now here in the world that isn't falling
apart after the idea of a dramatic
argument are introduced Mason says you
have to introduce your protagonist and
their Ordinary World what ordinary
emotions here is that the protagonist's
life essentially exemplifies their
ignorance of the theme of the argument
that you want them to believe eventually
in fact they believe the opposite of
that argument soon after we jump forward
to 2003 we'll like that protagonist Joel
Miller and his Ordinary World which is a
life stuck in time he's doing that
purpose for you he believes the exact
opposite of inaction being dangerous he
goes out of his way to avoid the passage
of time because acknowledging it and
taking action is what he thinks is a
true danger he ignores his birthday he
sleeps through his alarm he hates time
so much he even keeps his only
wristwatch locked away in a drawer one
change from the game by the way this is
all happening on Joel's 36th birthday
how old are you again
36. but in the video game it says 32nd
ironically that's right around how old
Craig Mason was when his first scary
movie came out and just like these first
events in the show that was also 20
years ago my God this is all a cathartic
release for Craig Mason to get his
frustrations out I'm working on scary
movies
I'm gonna draw from my pain of the
studio anxieties that were dealt my way
anguish of paying my dues to the system
was franchise sequels oh that's gnarly I
actually never picked up on that whole
idea of Joel kind of resistance Against
Time yeah that is a really really
interesting take subtly done yeah at
that time Craig said he'd actually been
hoping to move toward more adult fair
but his boss is at Miramax suddenly
dropped this scary movie thing in his
lab and then seven years went by so just
like Joel he finds himself in an
unfulfilling but relatively safe
category stuck doing the same thing
again and again but at least not risking
any true loss however the reality is for
both Craig again for Joel that time
keeps ticking anyway and that's embodied
by Joel's daughter Sarah she's the
antithesis to Joel's thesis she wants to
celebrate or at least experience each
moment she's growing she forces Joel to
acknowledge his birthday she constantly
asks about what's on the news she even
has a textbook on how to run a school
news program she probably would have
been a reporter sometimes Mason makes
Sarah this way to begin Joel's Evolution
using What's called the hegelian
dialectic that's a fancy way to say that
there's a Perpetual tug of war between
any two ideas a thesis and an
anti-thesis Hegel the guy that came up
with the dialectic he said that it's all
really just a cycle neither side really
wins so much as they give up on tugging
and land at a newly combined thesis a
point we call synthesis cool that's also
a point damn I love that yeah he ain't
done tugging now it's important to note
just because they are automatically
opposed doesn't mean Angel and his
daughter don't have a deep bond without
saying a word about it we can
subconsciously tell that the guitar in
the living room the poster of the Clash
and Sarah's room the open CD cases in
Joel's room even the magnet on the
fridge for the Austin City Limits Music
Fest those are symbols of a deep
connection they share dude this editing
is phenomenal yeah it's so engrossing
how far are we or seven minutes this is
Beautiful Jesus Christ
this is insane yeah absolutely there's
been a lot of those in a YouTube video
it's just kind of editing this this
feels like a TV special so mind-blowing
holy crap
top-notch job I can't get over it that's
gnarly a different way they can
communicate outside the limitations of
time through their appreciation for
music yeah that's it for those of the
last of a sequel you actually know that
Joel was once an aspiring musician part
of Joel and Sarah's morning routine
seems to be enjoying a bit of music
together but we can see the example of
how messages hide in that music as the
song playing here is White Flag by Dido
and afterwards I presume he says I don't
already
the lyrics are about someone who knows
that the days left in their relationship
are numbered
but I have no plans to move on or
Surrender their love
no detail wasted it's a sweet sentiment
but it's taken to an unhealthy place
with the bridge of the song
foreshadowing even 20 years from now
Joel's still gonna pretend he's moved on
almost seeming like he never was a
father at all but he's still secretly
hurting just the same
yeah
we could have predicted Joel's reaction
because as you remember he fast bodies
the thesis that you can stay safe as
long as you freeze time so that's why
it's up to Sarah the antithetical
character to remind him of the truth
somehow intuitively she knows their time
left is limited and by fixing Joel's
watch she's forcing him to bring time
back into his life because as she says
later you were never gonna do it for
yourself oh no to be clear Joel's
refusal to accept the passage of time
doesn't mean he's without purpose he's
actually driven to freeze time as a sad
attempt to be the ultimate protector
even from things like secondhand smoke
flip it out this is likely a philosophy
he inherited as not only is his watch
probably a hand-me-down from either the
Vietnam era or World War II but his
Hunter's knife is actually a Vietnam
standard issue Buck 110. whether or not
Joel was a soldier before since that
Desert Storm bumper sticker we see might
actually belong to Tommy definitely it's
clear that his family operates under the
belief that protecting others is the
ultimate purpose though through Sarah's
fascination with the engraving of wild
horses on that tucked away knife we can
see a symbol of Joel's past and his
Carefree spirit being locked away as
well
and for the zombie genre it's actually a
bit unusual to do so much establishing
of a character stuck in stasis rather
than just letting them react to the
insane chaos around them as we'll soon
see with the 20-year time Jump this show
actually skips the adjustment period
that entire other stories are set in
that's on purpose I'm not a huge fan of
the zombie genre when the genre creates
a situation in which every decision is a
matter of life and death I get fatigued
by it I am fascinated by people's
responses to things it's interesting
watch characters respond in various ways
to A disruption of stasis that can be
overcome speaking of stasis after the
movie three Craig was also trapped in
his own frozen career bubble pumping out
the same content over and over again
despite it not being fulfilling I mean
the pressure that we were under from the
weinsteins to make those movies as
quickly as possible was brutal and we
couldn't do them as well as we wanted to
do them but that's Craig just embodying
his own form of story structure your
hero can't shake themselves out of
stasis for some reason your video is
just making me wonder what was the scary
movie idea that he had
all of these deeper themes of synthesis
and all that what philosophical debate
does this parody movie have to offer
what is the thesis
keeps coming back it's a scary movie
three the easiest way to communicate you
know when you're trying to tell someone
about the last of us it's kind of like a
zombie game I don't think I've ever
called it a zombie game it's a survival
game but a lot of people often refer to
it as that just because there's some
similar things infection they behave
like rabbit I think having Craig Mason
on board is perfect when that's his
thought process because it allows him to
respect the material without going I
want to change the material a lot of
adaptations actually go wrong is when
they I don't really like this I'm going
to make it how I like it he's like the
perfect middle ground for it well and
the game is from the outside at least
has always sounded like it's not your
average zombie game it's a really story
driven thing and I feel like that's also
to kind of a saving grace that helps
this even further work yeah I don't know
what the best way is to leave something
I wish I did back in the world of The
Last of Us Sarah's teacher underlines
this moment of debate that Heroes arrive
to in their stories she asks the key
question in a sentence is where are you
songs in life just like in writing a
character is defined by their choices
and their actions a character who
doesn't take action is not only aimless
there aren't even really existing in
their own plot or in their own life
Sarah NPC self and for her father
against that ever ticking clock of
Reality by the way if you aren't sold on
Sarah's obsession with time let's just
check out where she goes next
what's really interesting about this
moment is what Sarah knows is true but
Joel is in denial and that's that time
is universal there's no hiding from it
for everyone everywhere no matter what
choices they make they're all about to
experience the exact same thing in the
very same moments the consequences up
next Sarah visits with her neighbors and
it's Mrs Adler who hints at the path
that Joel's gonna have to take people
out there need to get right with Jesus
three Nails Plus One cross equals four
given that's not to say Joel needs to
find Jesus apologize I need to seek
salvation or Redemption for his sins of
inaction find the light Craig Mason was
feeling this as well because after years
of making those spoof movies I would
argue the spoof is dead you could tell
it didn't feel good to be contributing
those Works to the world if there's one
thing that people who wrote comedy
features know it's that they're out
there with their knives and you are
gonna have to face the music sooner or
later that same stress about how little
time we all have is why Sarah lies to
Mrs Adler about her father being home
soon you know what my dad's gonna be
back real soon I should go she knows he
won't be home for hours but she also
knows how we spend our time is the only
thing about time that we can actually
control this is another lesson that Joel
actually needs to learn which is why
it's up to Sarah to point out that he's
failed on his promise and that he's home
late again it's 10. oh no he's not only
running out of time to celebrate his own
birthday he's running out of time to
spend with her literally this ultimate
failure in his current way of thinking
is similar to the last spoof movie that
Craig Mason made it's called superhero
movie and it was the first time he not
only wrote the spoof movie but he also
took the helm and directed it too and it
was by far his worst perceived it wasn't
just the worst reviewed it actually
earned a hundred million dollars less
wow no I'll tell you the worst situation
is when you have a bad movie that also
doesn't make a lot of money
it was for me to work on it and make it
and then also to watch
burn this experience was so bad it took
Craig 15 years to Don the director's cap
again and that was actually on this very
episode oh no way dang I missed the
episode of the show he directed you can
understand why we're paying so much
extra attention to the choices he made
within it but back to the early 2010s
the choices he made then implied an
initial search for salvation by focusing
on slightly higher brow comedy though
only slightly with his work on Hangover
2 and 3 and identity theft these films
were certainly more successful than
superhero movie but they still actually
only performed about as well as the
scary movies films did especially
critically just like how Mason could
have kept making spoof movies but his
refusal to showed hints of a desire to
change and Elevate Joel also makes new
promises he's gonna bring a cake
tomorrow he'll wear the watch though he
actually still jokes about refusing to
accept its time keeping
it
the thing is we know these people
haven't really changed yet we're just
seeing hints that they could you made
Identity Thief
I want to see the credit yeah I was like
is he a writer on it what did he do that
a hard time paying attention after him
he's got to be the writer of it yeah I'm
trying to pay attention to Phillips
video right now but I'm really stuck on
the fact that he made one of the movies
I I hate that movie so much most tedious
like arduous movies to sit through yeah
game has humor through the characters
and I think he brings that to life as
well I know he's not the only director
only writer on this show he's the
showrunner does an excellent job still
bringing those qualities to life in a
very beautiful way and I think this use
of time is is also very neat from a
writing standpoint when I watched the
first episode I thought it was more
about the ticking clock of the impending
doom coming around the corner and I was
aware of the whole thing with the watch
how it's going to break and Sarah and
all that but I didn't register
whatsoever oh there's actually a much
deeper meaning to this whole the
symbolism of time here of how it
reflects upon the characters internal
turmoils and struggles and the arcs are
gonna have to go on throughout the
series we know Joe hasn't really
embraced change because he even
hesitates to get his brother out of jail
he has to be guilted into taking action
tonight I'm in here all weekend nope by
the way that Tommy doesn't have the same
issue that Joel has he saw someone in
trouble and he immediately jumped into
savory
then as another clock points out just
how little time is left in this day
moments before midnight it's possible
that Joel's gonna come to regret this
action he's taking he might dig his
heels in even further and think he
should have never stepped away and
accepted this pull from outside his
bubble of safety that's because while he
doesn't know it at this time later he's
gonna remember that these are the last
moments of the last full day he could
have been with his daughter whether she
knew why or not she was right that this
time would be the end of their
relationship their final moments
together their last of us and the fact
that Joel's gonna blame himself for this
that's foreshadowed in one of the slight
changes from the game because yes both
stories deal with infected neighbors but
only in the show do we meet the adlers
and just like how Sarah cares for her
father she makes him breakfast she
encourages him to take vitamin C vitamin
C there's another child Mrs Adler who
dotes on her parent feeds her gives her
everything she needs but ultimately
she's killed by that parent so since
again these are new characters for the
show it's a purpose full choice to show
that ironically when the parent does
finally feed it's on the child
that's a distorted truth about how Joel
will come to feel like his actions cost
Sarah her life in some ways at least to
Joel it's like he did feed on her he let
her take a bullet for him
up next in Craig maiden's story
structure is the event that finally
shakes the hero out of stasis the
inciting incident is the moment their
belief shatters point of the inciting
incident is to specifically disrupt a
character's stasis it destroys it and it
forces a choice on the character that
belief-shattering choice for Joel is
made pretty quickly when he's witnessed
enough to know stasis ain't an option he
can't stay home they can't even stay in
Austin now you might think this would
force Joel to accept that trying to keep
Time Frozen isn't the right way to do
things but be it subconsciously or maybe
superstitiously you can imagine that
somewhere deep in his psyche he knows
the moment that he let himself wear a
working watch he let time unfreeze and
everything fell to [__]
haha
I think it would have been great if when
he showed up at the house he's like I'm
going back inside I don't want time to
work against me I'm taking this watch
off I'm gonna go down yeah I'm gonna put
that Ninja movie back on TV I'm staying
in the exact order of things of how I
like it to be as I refuse to adjust to
the times right now will not move
forward in inch yeah I would like to see
that version of the show at last one
episode yeah it's my birthday
hey if it kills me
that's how I write that's how I would
drive my themes home I'm just gonna
completely negate this inciting incident
and I am going to not you I have a
static character till I die ruin all
Logic for the whole audience now it's
all getting a little blurry about if
we're talking about the inciting
incident for the show or just for this
episode but either way let's just think
of it as the moment that everything
changes and The Dominoes start to fall
but first according to amazing after the
inciting incident there's got to be a
refusal to act and it's honestly usually
out of cowardice before they can make
the right choice the hero tries really
hard not to it's that tug of war we
talked about the yo-yoing of the thesis
and the antithesis they're pushing and
pulling until something snaps and for
Craig Mason this moment where he had to
leave stasis go on a limb and try to do
the right thing it came in 2015. by then
Mason had already been giving countless
interviews where he kept getting to ask
hey what's next for you and he'd often
say that he was looking to write drama
way back in 2011 he ended an interview
super excited about a project he was
working on even while he was writing The
Hangover too he said it's the first
non-comedy I've ever written it's kind
of a thriller and it's nice to flex that
muscle and show people there's another
kind of writing that I did that became
identity
[Music]
he wrote identity feed actually makes
sense now why the hangover of this whole
video just made me go like look at his
comedy filmography now yeah because The
Hangover 3 was unusually a thriller yes
absolutely not much of a comedy it's not
a pleasant film I I don't like that one
at all other than knowing that like
Craig Mason had this like itch and he
had just ridden a dramatic Thriller but
then next one became hangover I always
put that on Todd Phillips sure in the
direction he was going down because he
would eventually do things like war dogs
and Joker and Joker so I thought it was
just Todd Phillips wanting to take it in
that direction yeah maybe he did maybe
everybody was like we're sick of this
but you don't you don't do that so it's
just like funny to me to be like wow I
feel like there's something there yeah
why that became such a thriller and he's
clearly weren't movies that were gonna
scratch that drama itch for him but
everything changed in 2015. we can't
know how many times Mason had been
trying to do drama but clearly it wasn't
sticky so he decided he was gonna quit
on drama at least if he didn't get this
one last Hail Mary of a project to
Greenland he said if they don't like it
he wouldn't do it because something must
be wrong with him if they say no then
he's just wrong but in 2015 HBO said yes
and Craig Mason got to make Chernobyl
and honestly nobody thought he could do
it his friend scriptnote's co-host and a
successful screenwriter in his own right
John August put it pretty clearly you
doing Chernobyl that is like Jason
Statham doing a dromedy but eventually
the protection there's no way for them
working on some new adventure so for
Joel this time maybe because he was out
of time or maybe because he knew that
the survival of his darling his daughter
or for Craig his story that he obsessed
with it required them to break their
rules and Go full steam ahead so they
went for it and they went hard pitched
and I pitched him pitched so now in
making Chernobyl 20 years into his
career of screenwriting Craig Mason is
forced to learn new ways to connect to
an audience and make them care about the
story he's telling he's already taught
us that a story needs ways for people to
connect to the characters but now in
Chernobyl and later in Last of Us he's
adding a layer to the story structure
that's dedicated to why now a lot of
stories movies and television shows
demand a kind of discussion of relevance
that's because in stories audiences know
well either because they really happen
like Chernobyl or because we've just
seen them so many times like a zombie
apocalypse viewers inherently lacked
empathy for the characters since they
know where things are going people act
like they wouldn't make the same
mistakes so Mason says we have to show
them how we do make the same mistakes in
fact we are making them right now 2
today in the real world so for Craig
that is obsessed with grounding his
story about the 1986 meltdown of a
Soviet nuclear plant into the reality of
that moment of someone being as true to
those moments as possible but two having
a why now connected to our world at
least at the time that he was writing
and here's what he said was dominating
the headlines at the time Trump did make
a number of false statements in the
speech Trump's claim is false Trump
spent an entire day repeating a false
claim that President Obama literally is
the founder of Isis wasn't that the 2016
election was known for lies but rather
that America was having this discussion
about what the truth even was and if we
could trust our government to be honest
with us which unsurprisingly is why the
Soviet people let alone the rest of the
world didn't even really know what
happened at Chernobyl they didn't know
what caused it and they didn't know why
it took so long to acknowledge its
severity and so it's not a surprise that
the first spoken line in Mason's
Chernobyl is
the cost of lies and here's the thing
doing the right thing Craig finally
making it
Joel finally taking Swift action to
acknowledge the urgency of the events
around him they don't get replaced by
acceptance of this new way of life in
fact Our Heroes still want to reject it
they might not believe in their original
thesis anymore but they're not yet
willing to fully give in to the
antithesis so even though critics
actually completely loved Chernobyl and
the Emmy goes to Craig Mason and Joel
had protected his daughter from an
attacker he'd successfully guided her
out of immediate danger according to
Craig you have to show that your Heroes
aren't fully on board and then you have
to punish them both for taking the risk
and also for not giving themselves over
to it fully make your characters lower
their defenses by convincing them that
everything's gonna be okay and then
punch them right in the face
so for Joel he's unwilling to transition
to a place of accepting new information
and working on action together a
co-reliance instead he'd rather keep
Sarah in the dark prevent her from
having new information he's constantly
trying to Shield her perception from
what's actually happening
[Music]
you can look anywhere else what's really
sad is that this is a disagreement about
how to love someone Joel believes the
way to show love is to focus on
protection Sarah and Tommy they both
believe that love is shown in a
willingness to rely on each other
loves you he's dependent on me not the
same I think it's the same I definitely
the same and for Craig
cherished project that people
objectively acknowledge is fantastic but
rather than fully give in and accept
that he's a great dramatic writer he's
still seeking out negative reviews New
York Times did not like the review was
bad not bad in the sense of they didn't
like the show but bad in the sense it
was just it was poorly reading my father
it was stupid so Joel was wondering if
you can even face these new challenges
and Craig's List success might have been
a fluke like there's a reason they call
historical dramas and biopics Oscar bait
did he take a shortcut that means he's
not actually a great dramatic writer
considering the feedback of the internet
where naysayers always exist Craig would
have to have a superhuman amount of
self-assuredness to actually resist the
possibility that maybe his success
wasn't earned and so you're gonna have
to remember that mindset when I tell you
what insane project Craig Mason worked
on next and over to Joel he's still
unable to look forward it's actually
Tommy that has the foresight to know
where things are going he even
foreshadows how the Army is not going to
be their savior
I feel like you're right about all these
things that you're pointing out and I
love that it's being done in ways where
there's deeper meanings to it problem
that I think often happens with a lot of
filmmaking is you go down a path where
you know your themes and you know what
you want to talk about and then you're
just sort of talking about that that's
what you are communicating via the
dialogue of the characters and the
actions versus letting the characters be
like real people and then when you you
know dive deeper into it then you go oh
there is a deeper meaning here to what's
going on so as you're presenting all
this audience can still connect with the
immediacy of everything that you're
talking about all these scenes you're
pointing out a father protecting his
daughter that's why he's keeping his
eyes on her this whole time that's why
he's saying don't look at this because
she's a young girl but you know when you
do break it down you are seeing like
what is the subconscious core belief of
this character that is coming through a
brain that is making him say and choose
to do these things without drawing
attention to it in a way of going look
how brilliant we are yeah it's using the
language of behavior to have the
discussion rather than just making
characters sit down and talk about the
thing
[Music]
so moments later when this Soldier
doesn't abide by Joel's rules and how
this all should work
behaving in a way that's correct amazing
too I mean but in a way Tommy might have
anticipated it leaves Joel flat-footed
he just stands there and it costs him
everything as we now see his watch is
broken once again time freezes once more
for Joel some of his last words to Sarah
simply Another Broken promise you're
gonna be okay
now at the start of act two I'm gonna
get my watch fixed to us what our
protagonist is going to face next you
are taking their safety blanket away so
I want you to write your fearful hero
honestly what do they want a return to
what they had they want to go backwards
and believe it or not that is the gift
that is going to drive you through the
second act and that's why 20 years after
the events of the prologue Joel's
clinging to a frozen life again he's
closed off completely he wants to
retreat back to the idea that if he
simply accepts nothing new he'll stay
safe after all a monotonous disaffected
life is still technically living or is
it I really want to see if Craig Mason
and conjunction with Neil druckman with
all these character choices that I have
now been sold on yeah that that is part
of at least the show it seems like it
would be in conjunction with the game
but at least for the portrayal of Joel
in the show I would be curious to see if
they go back to some conversation or I
don't know they want to do a flashback
like have a conversation where you see
why Joel turned into that individual who
thinks and behaves this way you know
like we're seeing that he is that way
but I want to know like how we developed
into that basically like in 2003
like how he became before everything
goes well no yeah this this resistance
against time and yeah this thing to shut
off things about reality because that
setup of him as a character who has this
resistance against time is in
correlation with who he is 20 years
later because he has a hard time just
sort of accepting the reality of things
yeah and Sarah and Sarah's death can't
be the the originating cause of that
they're like it's almost like an
Aftershock that makes that part of his
character that much more entrenched so
yeah what led him to becoming this guy
in the first place yeah the child who
wanders toward the quarantine Zone shows
us what the future holds for something
that is technically alive but barely
taking in its surroundings and that
mindless trudging toward the New
Frontier hesitation because of what he's
been through a healthy distrust of where
things might go next that all might be
what Craig Mason was feeling when he
agreed to take on his next project after
Chernobyl this
what oh [__]
I feel a guitar today maybe a leopard
okay I'm not gonna pretend Charlie's
Angels was some insanely terrible movie
when I tell you what insane project
Craig Mason worked on next I said it was
an insanely terrible it was kind of an
insane follow-up to Chernobyl though
that's only because after years and
years of the lighthearted fair that
seemed so unfulfilling for that reason
you'd think you'd want to focus on the
work that would beat his soul he spent
years talking about wanting to get a
chance to show his dramatic Chomps not
his karate chops I'm sorry
the good news is so did he because for
some reason or another Craig Mason
actually left that project after only a
short while of working on it you didn't
take this job to fix other people's
grammar or fetch me tuna sandwiches and
tap
job because you have a vision for
yourselves and where he went well that
was that up I'll tell you this is
something that I honestly never thought
that I would be able to work on it's a
game called The Last of Us it is my
favorite video game and I play them all
the story is remarkable too remarkable
it made me feel things and what makes
him taking on this project all the more
interesting is just how scary it is for
him to do it it's a fear that never used
to exist after reflection perhaps I'm
not the right person to be writing this
story or that story but it is a fear I
mean the video game Community is not shy
so I would say you must do the thing
you're afraid of you must it's the caves
here to answer hold the answers you see
yes and video game fans aren't the only
people to be concerned about Neil
druckman the creator of The Last of Us
famously blew off Craig Mason when he
reached out to him about it damn but
that's the point of act two you have to
put the protagonist in a situation where
there's no going back and the likelihood
of failure is extremely high but you
also want the hero's past to be custom
designed to make them the exact right
person to tackle this new adventure only
someone who has experienced the loss of
a child is going to be able to fully
grasp the importance of keeping another
child alive and only someone who has
survived the deepest pits of critical
rejection has the resilience to
withstand The Impossible pressures being
placed on this project both heroes are
going to have the benefits and the
wisdom of their losses to calibrate
themselves for this journey so for Craig
when he planned the story for the last
of us he was able to use every aspect of
his career to ensure he'd knock it out
of the park with the show and some of
the parts of his career history that
he's using are actually pretty
surprising but we'll get back to those
wait a minute what was that graphic
there yeah it was like Journey language
balance patience oh that's cool
did you make this graphic damn the
crafts empathetic characters hold X to
grade I would of a script writing
software that is a video game like this
yeah be nice let's start with how what
he learned on Chernobyl comes into play
here like we referenced earlier
Chernobyl had this shortcut to Stakes
based on the fact that hey that thing
really happened on that show Craig took
small Liberties to add in some fiction
to a mostly non-fiction retelling but
could the opposite work too on the last
of us could Craig Mason take a mostly
fiction story and with some small
Liberties add in some non-fiction that
could ground the show to at least some
level of the realism that Chernobyl
I think yeah you can and here's how he
does it we've already seen some nods to
real world issues the opener had the
global warming reference and the thing
about a viral pandemic yeah it's a new
virus in Madagascar say it could be in
Chicago within a matter of weeks and
that threat even makes it all the way to
2003 where for some reason a student in
Sarah's class wears an n95 style mask in
front of an ironic sign that we'll get
back to except these are all just the
obvious parallels to the carnival but do
you remember earlier when I said I'm
actually not talking about covet here by
the way but more on that later I think
in order to connect this to the stakes
of our world today but still with the
severity of something as solemn as
Chernobyl Craig Mason and Neil druckman
made purposeful connections to
anti-Semitism and the most traumatic
event in modern Jewish history the
Holocaust I know that's so heavy but you
got to remember the best way for us to
analyze the intent of the creators of
the show is to focus on the changes that
they made from the story that we
experience in the game I feel like
visually I mean you know you're focusing
on the pilot but I they're I'm getting
flashes of moments in episode four when
Joel and Ellie are hiding out away from
the hunters and stuff there's so much
imagery that does evoke that maybe not
of real life documentaries or something
like that but you know at least the best
of the World War II Holocaust movies
yeah Mass dead occupations things like
that the way they hide out and the kind
of hideouts that they're in at the time
there are a lot of those visual
imageries that certainly evoke that kind
of vibe and so as we move forward I'll
go ahead and give you a warning now that
this is pretty dark material here when
the TV show story gets to 2023 this
entire section with the wandering child
is made new just for the show and it's
the first of many analogous moments to
the treatment of Jewish people in the
1930s and 40s for instance as the child
approaches the quarantine Zone with
barbed wire and signage similar to the
Jewish ghettos in places like Poland
he's taken by officers of fedra in the
games this bedroom represents the
fascist military dictatorship that took
power away from the US government in
response to the fungal outbreak in real
life the nsdap was Hitler's political
party who had been given control of
German police forces they used a global
economic crisis the one from the 1920s
to take their power and then they used
that power to Institute the mandatory
relocation of Jewish families from their
homes rounding them up into trucks
secretly Bound for concentration camps
all under an endless parade of false
pretenses those people falling out of
their cattle trucks have boarded them
believing they were being taken to new
lives in a new place the Nazis lied to
their victims at every step of their
Journey towards destruction actually it
was harder than I expected he's taken to
a sanitation area which is some of that
concentration camps was often referred
to as a quarantine Zone it began with a
forced trip to the showers typhus was
claiming 500 lives a month if it had
only been prisoners who are at risk the
SS would not have worried but the Nazis
dreaded this disease for themselves does
because of real concerns like typhus in
addition to totally [__] concerns
about other needs for sanitation with
the camps themselves actually being way
less sanitary than the outside world and
just like how the lies continue in the
show lies tied to the concept of
Sanitation or medicine were delivered to
all the people who entered the camps
what if I told you that after we gave
you some medicine
find your favorite
[Music]
favorites you want to play with the
difference between truth and lies can be
the difference between life and death
similarly as the Jewish people who were
selected for sanitation were led to the
showers they were made promises about
how after these warm showers they'd be
given new wardrobes soon and feasts
awaited these were the Jews final
minutes but the Nazis encouraged them to
believe in a future they did not have
what is your trade a Shoemaker the
officer would ask we need them urgently
report to me immediately after the line
just kept going it was holster and dress
in this one and those in the same room
they were even told to remember the
place where they put their clothes that
was when the reminder would come to tile
shoes into pairs so that afterwards you
won't have to waste time finding the
other shoe in fact the SS were thinking
practically the shoes of murdered
children would only be of use back home
if they came in pairs there's actually a
pretty famous Memorial site that shows
these Wow shoes left over from some of
these final victims and it kind of makes
you wonder where this shoelaces for sale
in the Boston quarantine zone are from
now you might watch this scene and felt
for the soldier who maybe was just
trying to bring some comfort to this boy
in his last moment you're safe and that
might even be a greater system though
but also you should keep in mind that
after 20 years of this it's pretty
likely that these are just standard
systematic precautions that would be in
place to prevent any risk so it's
strength to keep the Easter parties
caught they're afraid of the possible
Panic among them and if we're being
honest some of those lies are a lot less
comforting than the others
we don't want you falling out of the
chair now again I know this can seems
please yeah
I don't think so at all connected the
severity of those horrific events in
history to the events of this fictional
TV show I'm just trying to point out
that the intent behind the scripting
very likely was purposely trying to make
these connections remember aside from
the depiction of the Federer everything
I've just mentioned was newly added to
the story by Craig Mason and Neil
druckman and sure Craig Mason often
talks about his Jewish Heritage you know
how Jewish I am I'm so Jewish you guys
nobody's as Jewish as I am but he's also
spoken a bit about Neil drugman Neil
druckman he created the the game and the
story and he is Israeli he's definitely
more of a oh
while Craig and Neil were hard at work
on the scripting of this TV show at the
same exact time Neil was hard at work on
the last of us too the sequel video game
Craig and I started working while we
were at Naughty Dog finishing lasso's
part two so Craig would come over for
lunches and we would start breaking the
season what I had no idea wow that's
crazy because
there are like references without going
too big here to the second game for sure
and I could have swore wow that's just
like wild to me I mean could have
snailed drug from to multitask like that
yeah but
I really felt like they had the two
games and then they wanted to like
borrow elements from it but to be part
of that kind of just changes up the game
on the creative process when you could
be there while the creativity is
happening for the second game and then
how to really take that over it's a
different way of absorption versus I
played the first game I want to adapt
this and now you're absorbing how the
world's going to continue and what
elements or story lines can I bring over
to here for the show it's just insane to
me and it's so much of a time difference
that I'm like God damn this [__] takes
forever to make
both both of them have to take forever
to make and it makes you two Wonder like
I'm sure they didn't hamper anything for
one project or the other but yeah like
how did the formulation of the show
affect at all if maybe the formulation
of Last of Us Part Two and vice versa
you know yeah it's fascinating to think
about and that game had some very overt
references to Jewish culture this place
is a synagogue how can you tell that was
a percent Dina's character even
including comparisons of their
post-apocalyptic struggles to those of
Jewish history I like coming from a long
line of survivors you mean after
outbreak day that and the Holocaust
playing the game you even find this
letter from a rabbi that literally
Compares his grandfather escaping the
Holocaust to his family escaping the
outbreak the common connection he finds
is that despite the difficulties it's
people living people who matter so now
you might not be as surprised to see
when throughout the series there are all
kinds of references some more blatant
than others like in episode 3 and the
government are all Nazis the government
are all Nazis or more subtle references
to Jewish culture like this quick
glimpse of a man wearing a Gore
Lieberman shirt which is doubly relevant
by the way because Joe Lieberman was the
first Jewish person on a U.S
presidential ticket but also back in two
thousand 6 Al Gore won an Oscar for his
documentary about our failures to deal
with global warming
the presidency in 2000 global warming
could have maybe been staved off maybe
the cordyceps outbreak could have been
prevented who knows but actually I think
druckman's reasons for invoking the
Holocaust go deeper than just a surface
level purpose because you see when the
last of us two did come out it was very
well documented that the game had these
very clear themes related to the
israeli-palestinian conflict and for
some people that was a very
controversial inclusion that ended up
creating this heightened tone around the
game's discourse so then when an actor
compared the experience of playing the
game to the harrowing emotions brought
up by watching a film like Schindler's
List people got really mad in particular
this one journalist dug in pretty hard
and with the internet being the internet
not only did this somehow spawn a bit of
a meme where people would write jokes
about video games being compared to
incredibly tragic historical events but
then that same journalist joked that
oh my God Jesus got directly responded
to by Neil druckman himself and if you
didn't follow gaming news or discourse
you might have missed this controversy
but it actually did go pretty far and
wide to the point where eventually and
again as he was working on the scripts
for this Show with Craig Mason druckman
shared how severe the anti-semitic
attacks became no rather than focus on
any particular side of that debate I
want to step back and acknowledge how it
makes sense then that amidst all of this
the show's creators were feeling that
the topic of anti-Semitism was
particularly front of mind at the time
and also if you follow yes you said the
last few months sure still something
that people are currently a thousand
percent on both sides I'm referring to
her space lasers to Kanye West Kanye
West anti-semitic incidents in the U.S
it reached an all-time high last year
and here's where it connects back to
these storytelling techniques of Craig
Mason because it's not just about a
connection between our world and the
world of the story but rather connection
to the central dramatic argument and if
you remember for the last of us that
argument is that there's no greater risk
than inaction looking away hoping for
problems to resolve themselves so in
some ways Craig Mason it's like he's a
protagonist's Own Story yeah and by
doing a thing like the show is taking
that action without it feeling like
Craig Mason is talking to me yeah yeah
he's just letting the show and character
and story do its thing it's beautiful
because he seems like the kind of writer
who is capable of doing that anyway and
then to think that it is such like a
close collaboration with Neil druckman
who also has I think you know probably
similar levels of passion and concern
for you know the dramatic nature of the
real world it's fascinating to behold
and like even though I'm sure you know
we can draw narratives out of anything
this does feel like an interestingly
timed project with his growth as a
person and as a creative in this life
yeah Ken Burns probably the most famous
documentarian alive he just released a
brand new film specifically about how
that's the same exact message America
failed to learn during the Holocaust I
just want to say I love how you
implemented the Ken Burns effect
don't think I didn't notice that session
because I didn't know Ken Burns was a
person
after I was already Ken burnson in an
iMovie
Kim burns with the best of them we were
very surprised to learn that even as
early as 1933 there were thousands and
thousands of newspaper articles and
reports that we did have evidence that
something terrible was happening Burns
even goes so far oh my God blame a
number of deaths on America's mistake of
inaction that's on Roosevelt it's on the
state department it's on the Congress
but it's also on the American people and
just like Craig Mason knows that a
central dramatic argument from our past
is only interesting to us if we can
learn how to relate that argument to our
today Ken Burns is doing the same thing
sequence near the end of the film
includes some very recent events
Charlottesville chance of Jews will not
replace us a camp Auschwitz sweatshirt
at the Capitol on January 6th that's
clear from watching this the time to
save a democracy is before it's lost
prevention this is studying the
differences between fiction and
non-fiction we're seeing here that both
forms of Storytelling are equally
capable of teaching us the same lesson
and Craig Mason seems to think it's
especially true when they can borrow a
little bit from each other so as we move
forward a new world of Boston Post
pandemic a few more tragic circumstances
that are analogous to the Holocaust
become apparent with the public
executions the replacement of money with
internal credits and cigarette currency
to having to hide tools and valuables
and tragically the people of the camp
responsible for the incineration of
their own fellow man and it's clear that
the only way someone can steal
themselves for this dire a life is to
completely disassociate this woman was
struggling to throw the boy's body into
the fire but Joel does it without
freaking blinking it's like the dinosaur
foreshadowed he's pretending he's moved
on from mourning a child but the fact
that he still wears the gift of the ever
broken watch is a reminder that deep
down he's still suffering basically he's
in the simplest form of survival mode
which would have actually been pretty
familiar for Craig Mason who spent years
of his career not just on those spoof
films but also as a go-to script doctor
picking up any odd job separating
fulfillment from his career with the
need to make a living this is what made
it so much more impressive for Craig to
make these dramatic projects because he
openly has admitted they don't pay
nearly as well as the other work he was
doing I'm going to spend a lot of time
now on something that I'm not going to
make a lot of money on but I just care
about though they can't say that why
that's an American way it goes
uncredited on a lot of the scripts he
works on and Joel well he's clearly done
some bad stuff in these last two decades
dates including smuggling drugs to the
fascists it's actually ironic that a
twitching hand in Sarah's classroom was
designed of a possible underlying
infection because the same could be said
for this officer's twitching hands
except his infection is one of addiction
showing the soldiers this way is also a
new addition to the story and while in
some ways it humanizes them it's also
another connection to the crystal meth
and opiate addictions of Nazi soldiers
what Joel says oh really I didn't know
about that yeah the more you shoot
people the harder it is to sleep I guess
now I know this analysis feels like it's
taken this pretty dark turn but I think
that's because the story really does too
in fact it's appropriate that the first
episode's title is when you're lost in
the darkness now of course the concern
that when working on something so
precious after so much serious work and
conversation and just darkness is that
Craig just like Joel could lose himself
in that Darkness certainly Neil
druckman's recent experiences weren't
really providing much levity to the
situation just like how Joel shows no
signs of acknowledging his sweet even
sometimes kind of silly past with his
daughter we stopped having any sort of
semblance to a connection to Craig's
past as a comedy writer it's all as dark
as Chernobyl but with an even higher
body count so now we have Craig on this
mission to deliver this incredibly
serious somber piece that's gonna prove
that video game adaptations can work and
Joel on a mission to save his brother
though arguably he might not even need
saving and both are doing it just like
the truck without the battery so it
seems like that one of the keys is the
classic thing of what makes great
writing and storytelling is allowing
yourself to throw yourself into this
store in a weird way it could be
unintentional or intentional but some
type of honesty about yourself and
vulnerability about yourself and allow
that to be weaved in as the story
progresses that is the the question
posed at the top of this is how do you
make it and how do you identify the
emotion and I feel like like with
everything that's being broken down in
this video keeps coming back to Craig
Mason and his shitty spoof coming let's
just ruined his life and put him in the
most despairing Place possible I think
that's what people really are getting at
when they say right which you know it's
not just like oh take something that you
know the details about it's like take
the life that applies to you and the
experiences and imbue the story with
those debates and issues and feelings
somehow rather than just like you were
an accountant right About Accountants I
feel like it gets boiled down that way
but yeah like take this life and find a
way to make this apply to the fiction
you're you're telling there's some
essential component missing from these
utilitarian missions so we get the same
solution for both of them enter Ellie
born in this absolute Darkness she is
the light we meet her and she's bathed
in it she speaks and we get the first
thing resembling a lighter tone in this
entire post-apocalyptic world seven
eight
eight [__] you she's not just a spot of
brightness in Joel's future she's
actually an outlet for Craig Mason to
bring in a sense of Comedy that exists
in the world too and I don't say that to
me that this show needs joke breaks what
do you want I want you to forget this
ever happened done
now your [__] has pretty much ruined my
week and I'd like to go home and drink
till my face stops hurting so are we
good
release the left track cut
[Laughter]
there's a wacky version of this whole
show somewhere in a drawer I don't know
what Craig Mason thinks of that SNL
sketch that they did of The Last of Us
he wrote and directed the Mario one oh I
haven't seen it yet if it's more of a
spoof of Mario but brought it HBO
sensibility in general yeah okay I get
but there's like Pedro Pascal stars in
it so I think that would be oh I want to
know his response to that it's gonna
Inspire him maybe we could change it to
season two a little bit now um second
Mario Brothers movie Craig Mason will
take over I say bring back some of that
spoof comedy material Craig Mason yeah
you got plenty of zombie and infection
movies to draw for him just start
throwing blatant references I say that
because even on our darkest days the
real world still has moments of levity
there's another zombie show that
personally got a bit hard for me to
watch not only because it was becoming
exhausting to always be dwelling in
death like crazy ex-girlfriend
Mason told us in one of the very first
episodes of his podcast over 10 years
ago that he knows deep down comedy and
drama should coexist whether you're
writing a drama or a comedy you must be
writing drama they really aren't that
different oh also you might have noticed
that Ellie lied about her name with
Veronica being a slightly fitting name
for the role that she's gonna play for
these men since Saint Veronica at least
uh in non-canonical Bible stories she's
the woman who saw Jesus bearing the
cross on his way to Calvary and in her
own small way as she reached out and
supported him she offered him her veil
to wipe his blood and sweat from his
face these Jewish writers implemented my
Bible
speaking to it didn't click until just
now with the whole Christian thing and
now I'm on board yeah before I was like
I don't know about this second he bring
some Jesus talk into here I'm on board
now I'm like now that's my Jew Amen
brother
you're not Jews for Jesus of course this
isn't the type of Salvation that Joel's
hoping for since he clearly prefers the
Roadies onward test unlike what Sarah
would have wanted this is almost a
Bizarro relationship to the one he had
with her here neither person wants to
take responsibility for the other and
both seem eager to break promises now I
promised Robert that he wouldn't hurt
him
very much like
Joel even finds himself on the opposite
end of the withholding of information
well where is he don't know Daddy don't
know is it from terrorists no no that's
likely because this isn't the actual
relationship he needs in his life Tess
has a bit smaller role in the game and
while her character is actually
fascinating here it doesn't make their
parent any healthier they're both happy
to live in stasis and we see what
extended stasis does to a person moments
later the infected who was less there on
his own the fungus eventually fully
overtook him he grew into the wall
there's no bit of humanity left that's
very near where we find Joel these days
the the thing is this Behavior it's not
because of the tragedy the world's
experience is still representative of
Joel's own individual issues we know
this because if Joel comes to function
as a pseudo Father Figure to Ellie we
can look back at her relationship with
Marlene as that of a pseudo mother
figure this all is a lot more apparent
in the game but Ellie even asks Marlene
my [__]
Joel and Marlene feel responsibility to
protect Ellie but even this early on in
the story we know they have completely
different philosophies about who's
worthy of living and the value of one
person versus the greater good you need
it for a better reason than you they
don't know offense but Tommy's just one
man yeah it's actually really
fascinating because Joel while
experiencing lossy he knew of the world
prior to this outbreak where Ellie while
there's some traumas to uncover that at
that time of recording this video the
show has not necessarily fully gone into
just yet so I don't want to talk about
it but Ellie represents someone who's
born post this outbreak yet is very much
more humorous she seems to be more
engaged and Lively and it's it is an
interesting parallel to draw because you
got a guy who is so traumatized and so
affected but he at least knew of a life
before all this where Ellie born into
this so what you're saying about this
all boils down to Joel as an individual
that's what I was trying to get out
early here when I was like I wanted to
see why he is the way he is prior to
uncovering that individual piece because
he's always sort of been this way it's
just only been Amplified by day of
outbreak and 20 plus 20 years or
something Marlene actually represents
another nuanced connection to our real
world which Tess clearly labels for us
it's Che guevar of Boston Che was a
controversial figure whose role in
history kind of depends on who you ask
some people think his revolutionaries
had the right idea but others call out
that just like the fireflies in pursuit
of something that could be Noble they
were far too willing to let innocent
people get hurt nonetheless
revolutionaries are known for taking
action and responding to the times oh
yeah cool as we know still believe
something closer to the opposite of that
in fact as he tells Ellie what are you
doing killing time the dude is literally
killing time in the middle of one of the
craziest days of this girl's life he
hates time the only effort he's willing
to put in is to actively prevent Ellie
from being able to engage with them
further specifically in the same way his
daughter did because like Sarah Ellie
quickly guesses there's a secret way to
communicate with Joel through music the
radio is a smuggling code right
he's like bumblebee
I'm just talking through the radio
[Laughter]
it's why her first observation of the
man is this your watch is broken
just like Sarah Ellie knows that watch
represents everything wrong with troll
except what's different about Ellie from
Sarah is that Ellie belongs in this
world she's more at home in this world
than she would have been in Sarah's we
may meet both of them near windows but
Ellie's difference is symbolized by the
butterfly that hangs over this one just
like how an infected human normally goes
through a metamorphosis to become
something monstrous Ellie will soon
learn is technically infected yet she's
transforming into something beautiful a
harmonious balance between a desolate
human existence and a thriving fungal
one this is actually New Testament
fungal form of her and Joel at the end
of the opening credits but there's
actually a much better symbol for them
but I'm going to get to in a minute but
before that remember when I told you in
a tug of war between two ideas thesis
and an anti-thesis they'll land
somewhere in the middle a point we call
synthesis that's what Ellie is she's the
synthesis of the Two Worlds and of the
two philosophers
but a complete subservient Reliance to
somebody isn't right either Ellie
represents the idea that we need to cool
forward and mutually lean on each other
as we go that way I think most of the
show is going to take place in this act
two of Joel's character Arc but I do
think we've had a few moments that could
represent the final Maze and story step
that I'm going to go over the element of
doubt this element of Doubt creates a
natural conflict with the protagonist
because of course I believe this you
believe that but they have to have the
capacity to see that maybe there is a
better way we've seen this tug of war
continued a few times but the biggest
example is right here when Joel's
brought back to the exact moment time
stopped for him way back in 2003. the
moment where inaction caused his
daughter her life so going out on a limb
he decides to take a risk instead of the
weak pleading and otherwise just
standing there he makes a different
choice this time he takes action
[Music]
foreign
the ripples of action do mean that the
clock is ticking again Joel's never
going to be able to return to his
ordinary world but at least now he still
has his daughter figure there to protect
it turns out his purpose isn't ruined by
taking action and this deeply challenges
Joel's belief system and the Depeche
Mode song that plays never let me down
again it hints at what new beliefs are
for me
Joel will be Ellie's friend
he'll be there to protect her
as long as she listens to him and
follows his rules
he's not going to let his daughter down
again I love cues like this and Craig
Mason isn't gonna let us down either
because he's the exact right person to
adapt this show hangover for one of them
oh this you know what I I do love it I
love it I love God I love it that's
because everything he's ever worked on
has led to this moment all the things
that you do prior to something were
necessary for one reason or another to
get you to what you're doing at this
moment yes he has a deep appreciation
for video games and yes he's
experiencing creating a serious
successful show that posed complex
social questions but it's his lifetime
experience and his comedic writing that
makes him so perfect for this yes even
the spoof movies writing a spoof movie
is just about loving a genre so deeply
that you understand the nuances of the
category and [__] great Point
great ass boy
down beloved genres like horror
superhero movies and identify the parts
that most resonate with the audience
he's now doing that for the zombie genre
and the HBO massive World built-in genre
in the video games are even a little bit
of Western is thrown in there he's
pulling the parts we need as an audience
to connect to our favorite elements of
those genres and the reason he's so dang
good at it is because of those spoof
movies unlike an impression or a coffee
or an homage those movies are graded on
whether or not they click with a feeling
the audience has about that genre it's
like how the best comedians know it's
their ability to empathize with the
audience that is key to them accepting
their message which is how a good
stand-up is able to play a room full of
people like an instrument his or her
words can control the emotions of an
entire Audience by just knowing how to
relate to them so comedy taught Craig
Mason how to tell the stories of flawed
people spoof movies taught him how to
create relatable moments in flawed
genres and the two together have given
us a familiar genre but with a deeper
human connection to it than we've ever
felt before because comedy isn't about
thousand zombies piling on top of each
other like he has to get over a wall
comedy is about The Human Condition
there needs to be a period of resistance
and then we begin the adventure just as
I said what Ali represents for Joel The
Last of Us represents for Craig Mason he
knows the two sides of the argument are
tired of pulling away from each other
and I'm not telling Craig Mason this
he's telling us don't worry he's got
this I mean look at all the work he put
into just structuring this thing and the
attention to detail because of his love
for this project and his desire to get
it right oh and speaking of those great
details remember a few minutes ago when
I told you but there's actually a much
better symbol for them that I'm going to
get to in a minute now before I tell you
what that symbol is I gotta thank you
for watching this video this far this is
a brand new channel and like Joel and
like Craig we're also going out on a
limb here we're trying to take a chance
and do some something different
hopefully we're making something people
want if you're a supporter on patreon by
the way thank you so much we cannot do
it without you and if you're not that's
fine too you can help us out by
subscribing commenting and mostly
sharing this video with other people you
think it would resonate with trust me
and speaking of that private playlists
relationships that's the symbol of
synthesis I wanted to share with you the
symbol that represents Craig in this
show our relationship with him and with
Neil the needed balance between the
natural world of the fungus and the
artificial constructions of man and
Joel's relationship with Ellie it's in
the final shots of the very first
episode the buildings yeah we see these
buildings more clearly in episode two
but for now remember this is Craig's
directorial debut after over a decade
this is what he wants us to focus on
this symbolism in this moment two
utilitarian Towers covered in natural
growth leaning on each other in a
mutually Reliant love just like the kind
Sarah believed in all amidst a storm of
danger we still hear the words oh [__]
man soundtrack The Thunder crashing and
even an infected Screech at least for
now he's got me man you're awesome it's
not going anywhere it's persevering it's
in perfectly synthesized balance and it
as far as symbols go it might outlive
them all but for now it's a great
snapshot of what really is the last of
us actually
great superim position fantastic man
that was amazing a plus man this is
inspiring what I really loved about your
video here is it's really easy to get
lost in the technical side of what
you're doing like oh this is different
you're sitting and there's multiple
camera angles you got one on a on a
track slowly moving around there's a lot
of beautiful fanciful editing going on
throughout and great visuals like it was
like the production quality on it was
insane but the thing that I really want
to credit you on right now is you still
look like you're in good shape so good
job after all that I know you're just
perfectly yeah yeah good job man I know
it's hard to get that shirt you're still
keeping it up it accentuates your
muscles that look like you're trying too
hard no what I want to say is that the
video like buys you into like all right
we're getting some different subject
ideas and then as opposed to Leading
with the really dark deeper stuff like
super deep dark stuff like like the
Holocaust parallels and whatnot and what
I love is that you told the story here
about a store and you still made it like
a character-driven narrative via through
Craig Mason journey of adapting this and
I thought that was really cool because
you know you're especially when you're
ending this video off I'm being inspired
by this journey you're sending out with
film wise I think that is very present
here with how this video narratively is
structured like I found myself going
down like the dark Death paths with the
video as it's being presented and then
it comes back with a hopeful end it's
like you found the the synthesis at the
very end as well within your own video
and I think that's really clever of how
this was done yeah I thought this was uh
an actual it felt like a documentary
yeah you know you said part one and I
thought it was going to end on like a
real Cliffhanger of sorts and it doesn't
feel that way like this really feels
like something that could be on
television because a story was told like
oh exciting we're introducing a new
topic we're going to go into the weeds
of things and we're gonna go real dark
then we're gonna swing back to something
a little bit more hopeful and on top of
that you were also telling the Craig
Mason journey and how that's affected
your life and I think that's really cool
I really really love the way this was
done because there's so much emotion
into it versus just breakdowns or really
intuitive insightful video essay because
it's kind of all that but more yeah I
feel like what's so lovely about this
especially for for me as viewers like
yeah you can look at any piece of art or
whatever it is in a vacuum and and
examine it for its own merits and what
it's trying to say just as a piece on
its own but what often resonates with me
just in my own time or if I'm enamored
with a project is learning about the
people who made it and kind of
understanding what came together in the
real world to produce what I'm enjoying
so much now and I think here yeah you
did a great job people narrative eyes
life but this didn't feel too contrived
or anything like that or like you're
forcing this Craig Mason's story to
parallel like it felt very natural and
yeah like an interesting and grossing
tale about how this got made and and why
these people why now but also yeah what
is it doing Beyond just oh here's how
it's kind of like the game or here's how
it nods to this movie or yeah
interesting uh sort of documentary on
the Vitality of all these things I mean
even how you brought it around with
Craig Mason and his struggles with the
time when he was working in comedies you
know so much of this kept seeming like
all right you know he had a hard time
with comedies he was burnt out by
Hollywood and it wasn't really wanted to
do then he found Chernobyl all right but
you're just wrapping it all around too
but that's what led him here and here's
what he learned from there that allowed
that again it's like Craig Mason what
you're talking about with this whole
thing with thesis and and antithesis
when you're talking about those I'm like
you're also doing that with Craig Mason
threat and I didn't really even see that
until the ending like oh [__] he's the
synthesis Phillips video is doing the
thing you know as opposed to just
telling it you are we are experiencing
it and I think that's cool like I really
found this video to actually be an
experience 100 and a narratively really
enjoyable one so this was uh there's
nothing quite like this that I I've seen
because it's doing like all the things
that I love from you know anything from
like what heavy spoilers will do to
Patrick H Willems to high top films like
you're doing all that but with like this
Netflix level type of documentary it's
like some kind of cable special or
something like that you might tune into
like the yeah it's really polished and
really Punchy and really engaging I was
really impressed with this because I was
expecting it more be like all right
there's some cool like information in
here it's not like an Easter egg video
but it's in some ways like the ultimate
Easter egg video the Thematic Easter
eggs yeah yeah it is it is breaking down
why this project is as great as it is
and as rich as it is and as personal as
it is and I wasn't expecting to find
something that would be so moving and
inspiring because it's inspiring on the
level of
seeing how Craig Mason got to where he
is but it's also inspiring that this is
put together because everyone was
telling me like it's such an impressive
video and you know you kind of just
expect yeah it's probably like really
cool to look at and I love Last of Us so
I'm sure it'll be good
yeah but I was not expecting the the
kind of Journey that we went on and how
clever it is without it seeming without
you even telling me without like I mean
like not like Philip texting me I mean
like you it's like telling me in the
video like and see if I've done the
thing too oh [__] he's done the thing
but without saying that you've done the
thing well in that way I think that's
part of what separates something like
this out too is because not to not to
slight anybody else's approach but this
one it's like you could watch this both
for your appreciation of just the show
in the game as they are but also you
could study this for writing tips and
things like that because it's a
comprehensive place to show the
Creator's input but also then to
extrapolate breakdown and illustrate how
that approach then is put to work and
then you're demonstrating it's kind of
like you brought up that thing about
parodies and spoofs about like you have
to know the thing inside and out in
order to authentically provide that kind
of experience in here I feel like in
breaking down the approach to story like
you said synthesis uh you know thesis
antithesis and then synthesis you you
demonstrated that here in what feels
like a very graceful and articulate way
and so it's like you can get your fan
Rush from this but you can also get your
creative you know nutrition in a way it
feels like from this too like I get why
this took you so long to put together so
you can't do this once a week
I know you had some help here but I know
like it's mainly you who edited this
video and uh with help from the lady
you're dating uh what's Rachel yes
Rachel shouts out to Rachel I think the
writing on this it's really easy to just
look at the production quality of what
you have assembled here but this is the
script on this is pretty nominal I am
really Blown Away by what I just watched
it is it's intimidating it is yeah it's
like intimidating and inspiring so I'm
just gonna look at my most recent Last
of Us reaction view count to feel better
about myself
you're doing great don't tell your
channel is just way too big
I only got like that many views and now
it makes sense why you have this many
views now no you always trend on this
thing that was wild that was a tour de
force that was wild because yeah I was
like man it's a long video
the thing is it doesn't feel like it's
what just shy of an hour like I was so
engrossed and then we were done and I
was like oh we're here we're here
already yeah no I think everything all
around was um pretty spectacular pitch
this to TV man
this really could be this really could
be a show or like a screening you got
invited to for somebody's yeah like yeah
not quite feature length documentary but
you know it's just as good as that
anyone deserves to interview Craig Mason
it's you and that's that's what I feel
right now part way through watching this
I was like you know you never know how
anybody will feel but I I hope he sees
this and appreciates it and feels
validated right there's another Hall in
New York Times piece
such a [__] video
and then he'll write his own version of
this video yeah it'll be even better
um yeah guys subscribe to filmwise I
hope your next one comes out sooner than
later this was phenomenal yeah I really
mean that this hats off this is truly
phenomenal also we'll talk with you guys
soon again and watch the original video
link at least go go there and give it a
like all right I'll see you guys soon
[Music]